in corona satz der in diesen stunden
eingeschlagen hat wie eine bombe der
kommt vom chef des so wichtigen
robert-koch-instituts von lothar wieler
und gesagt hatte ihn vor etwas weniger
als 24 stunden der vergleich darin
corona mit der grippe in solcher
vergleich der galt er bislang als
gefährliche verharmlosung der wurde
immer den querdenkern zugeschoben jetzt
also dieser satz vom lka chef der satz
von lothar wieler hat ja zwei
interessante komponenten erstens er soll
ich hier ausdrücklich benutzt werden um
sozusagen vor der grippe zu wahren er
soll hier ausdrücklich benutzt werden um
am ende menschen angst zu machen vor
allem nächsten chaotischen winter um für
die grippeimpfung zu werben um für
weitere impfungen zu werben das ist die
eine komponente dass ein vergleich
herangezogen wird um weiter neue angst
zu schüren die zweite interessante
komponente ist das was eben gesagt habe
dass dieser vergleich bisher
quasi als rechtsextreme
verschwörungstheorie galt ja menschen
die gesagt haben naja wie ähnelt sich
das eigentlich mit der grippe wie
vergleichbar ist das mit der grippe wie
ist es bei der krankenhaus auslastung
ganz entscheidender punkt lothar wieler
spricht dann nämlich von der krankenhaus
auslastung das ist schon in früheren
grippesaison volle krankenhäuser gegeben
hat wie ist das eigentlich beides corona
bei der krankenhaus auslastung
eigentlich vergleichbar mit der grippe
da hieß es ihm so wie kann man das das
ist eine relativierung von corona das
kann man und es ist sofort sofort jeder
der diese fragen gestellt hat ist
verordnet worden im lager der wii ist
natürlich immer sofort heißt rechten der
rechtsextremen der querdenker szene
jetzt stellt sich und familie vor die
presse weil er dafür werben wir für die
grippe zu impfen und hebt quasi die
grippe auf eine stufe mit corona wenn
ich mir überlege wie menschen in den
letzten anderthalb jahren für diese
frage dafür dass sie sich als
medizinische laien die frage gestellt
haben sind wir in einer historischen
ausnahmesituation
sind die intensivstation wirklich so
deutlich mehr belastet als in einer
grippesaison wie diese menschen aus der
bundesregierung heraus diskreditiert und
teilweise bis hin zu kriminalisiert
worden sind dann wundert es mich schon
dass das jetzt auf einmal offenbar die
lieben ihr eines regierungs instituts
ist ja dass mit diesem vergleich und
dieser vergleichbarkeit und dieser
gleichstellung dafür wirkt sich für die
grippe impfen zu lassen wir sehen da er
neben dir die bilder aus der
pressekonferenz laufen wir schauen jetzt
einmal rein was rk ii chef lothar wieler
gestern zu einem vergleich grippe und
corinna ganz genau gesagt hat
google und grippe auch influenza genannt
die haben viele gemeinsamkeiten beide
sind atemwegsinfektionen beide
verbreiten sie soll dort wo menschen
zusammenkommen und natürlich auch
besonders in geschlossenen räumen beide
sind vor allen dingen für ältere
menschen und auch für chronisch kranke
menschen ein risiko
ein risiko für ältere und chronisch
kranker und zwar beide krankheiten
corona wie auch die krippe also direkt
der vergleich gezogen ein vergleich den
man sonst eher mit sehr vorsichtigen
fingern angefasst hat es gibt vor allem
diese interessante formulierung die sich
überall da verbreiten wo menschen
zusammenkommen und da glaube ich
entsteht gerade etwas was mir persönlich
angst macht es hat sich ja ausgebreitet
in anderthalb jahren pandemie diese
besessenheit dass man sich vor allem was
es an risiken auf der welt gibt
irgendwie schutz kann und dass auch der
staat ein irgendwie davor schützen
muslim ist natürlich nicht so das symbol
dafür ist natürlich die maske und ich
erlebe viele menschen inzwischen die
sich diese maske eigentlich gar nicht
mehr wegdenken können und wollen und das
was lothar wieler da sagt ist natürlich
genau die vorlage dafür zu sagen na ja
mit der maske das ist doch eigentlich
gar nicht so schlimm und die grippe
verbreitet sich ja genauso wie corona
und die grippe kommt ja auf jeden fall
und sie ist nicht besiegt und die
impfquote niedrig warum behalten wir die
maske nicht dann einmal bleibt auf
weiter
aktuell eltern die ihre kinder weiter in
die schule schicken die masken fliegt
wird jetzt durch die eltern durchgesetzt
aktuell und nicht mehr durch die
regierung durch die politik habe einfach
in zu breiter weise verliebt in
restriktive maßnahmen und da kann man
immer nur sagen es braucht menschen
müssen irgendwann entscheiden normal
weiterzuleben sie können sich nicht auf
institutsleiter und politiker verlassen
ihnen das vorzugeben sie müssen sich
selber entscheiden und dieser zeitpunkt
ist jetzt
[Musik]